I'm super excited to be joined by my
secret math tutor YouTube channel here
along with Mario's math tutoring to go
through this final exam review with you
Algebra one I'll have a link in the
description below where you can download
this free worksheet if you want to
follow along and do these problems let's
get started into part one I'm gonna be
working through the odds and my secret
Matthew is going to be doing the even so
the first problem we have seven minus
two times the quantity 3x plus 1 equals
negative 7 how do we solve for X well if
it's a multiple choice problem you know
you can always put in you know whatever
the values are a b c d e in for x and
see if they equal negative seven that's
always an option if it's like a multiple
choice test but if you're trying to
solve for x and you're trying to show
your work algebraically what you want to
do is you want to simplify this left
side here first okay
simplify the left side as much as you
can simplify the right side as much as
you can so what i'm gonna do here is i'm
going to distribute not two into the
parenthesis but see that minus two you
can think of this as a negative two and
so i'm going to be distributing meaning
i'm going to be multiplying that into
the parenthesis see how these are right
next to each other with nothing in
between that means x or multiply so if
we do that we get negative six x minus
two and then we still have the seven and
bringing down equals negative seven so
the next thing we want to do is we want
to combine like terms okay so that the
seven and the negative two add up to
positive five bring down the negative
six okay now what we want to do is we
want to get the variables on one side
numbers on the other you want to
separate them so in order to do that i
want to get the i have the variables on
the left i want to get the numbers on
the right to get the numbers on the
right half to get rid of them on the
left i'm gonna do that by subtracting 5
from both sides so if we do that we get
negative 12
these cancel we have negative 6 equals
negative 12 and the last step is you
know we just want to get one of the x's
by itself just get that variable x by
itself so the opposite of multiplying by
negative 6 would be divide both sides by
negative 6 you wanna make sure you do it
to both sides to keep it balanced these
are going to cancel one another out and
we get x equals positive 2 because a
negative divided by a negative is a
positive now if you want to check your
work and you have time go ahead and put
that two back in for ax you know and
simplify and make sure you get
oh seven then you know you've got a
correct let's go ahead and look at a
problem and this problem were tasked
with solving the equation 2x minus 7 all
divided by 3 is equal to X divided by 12
in order to solve something like this we
might work on getting a common
denominator here in the bottom so I
could multiply the top and bottom of
this equation on the left side here by 4
and of course what's that going to do is
it's going to give us a 12 in the bottom
and we're going to have to go through
and distribute in that top piece so I'll
give us an 8 X minus a 28 I'll divide it
by and then the bottom we're getting
that 12 equals x divided by 12 now you
can really see the importance of doing
that since the denominators or the
bottoms are equal it means that the tops
or the numerators must also be equal so
we'll only need to focus on those top
pieces excellent now that we have those
we can work on getting the X's together
and really isolating it so let's go
ahead and subtract an X from both sides
that looks like a pretty good idea so we
get a 7x minus 28 is equal to 0 and we
can move that 28 to the other side as
well right this one is almost done one
last step divide both sides by a 7 and 7
goes into 28 4 times so then we have our
solution that X is equal to 4 okay let's
go to number 3 now so here what we have
is we have an absolute value see those
vertical bars absolute value bars so to
solve an absolute value problem what you
want to do is you want to try to get
that absolute value portion by itself on
one side of the equal sign so because
the negative 4 in the absolute value are
right next to each other that means
multiplication right we're gonna do the
opposite we're going to divide both
sides by negative 4 ok so those cancel
out we have the absolute value of 2x
minus 1 equals positive 3 because a
negative divided by a negative
but then what you want to do from here
is you want to actually split this up
into two equations see whatever was in
here originally could have been negative
three and when you take the absolute
value that makes it positive three or it
could have been positive three when you
take the absolute value that's also
going to be positive three so the
absolute value always makes it positive
so kind of working backwards we're gonna
break this up into two X minus one
equals a negative 3 or 2x minus 1 equals
positive 3 and remember in math or
actually means both right means Union
not like one or the other it's actually
both so we're going to add one to both
sides okay so if we do that these are
going to cancel we get 2x equals
negative 2 and then instead of x two
we're going to divide both sides by two
and that comes out to negative one over
here we're going to add one to both
sides okay so that comes out to 2x
equals four instead of multiplying by
two we're going to divide both sides by
two and x equals two now again if you
want to check your work that's a nice
thing about algebra often times you can
just take those values put them back in
and make sure that you know they work
out in this problem we want to find the
percent of change now of course there's
a wonderful formula for this that you
can use and that formula essentially
goes that you want to take your new
price subtract out the old price and
divide everything by your original or
the old price how that applies to our
particular problem is we see that the
new price is $60 whereas the old price
was $50 and we're going to divide that
by the old price of $50 all right so we
just have a little bit of math here to
work out 60 minus 50 will give us a 10
all divided by 15 and 10 divided by 50
is the same as 1/5 or written as a
decimal 0.2 and of course we want the
percent of change so we definitely want
to write this as a percent so let's go
ahead and move that decimal place over
two times and we will call this 20
percent so that'd be the percent of
change if our original price is 50 and
it now gets bumped up to 60 okay number
five what we want to do here is we want
to graph these points
you know plot these points and then we
want to label which quadrant that they
fall into now the important thing to
remember is that you want to start over
here in this upper right-hand corner
this is our first quadrant or it could
use a Roman numeral a one second
quadrant third quadrant and fourth
quadrant so it goes counterclockwise
like that from the upper right-hand
corner and the other thing you want to
pay attention to is is just like
alphabetical order see it's like X comma
Y so we're going ax left and right
y up and down so I usually just do the X
first so negative two we start at the
origin left 2 and the minus 3 tells us
to go down 3 1 2 3 right about there
I'll just label that point a ok and
that's another quadrant so here we'll
just write right here 1 2 3 ok for a
letter B now this point 4 comma negative
1 so we have 1 2 3 4 down 1
that's point B and you can see that it's
in Quadrant 4 number see here 3 comma 2
so we're going write 3 on the x up 2 on
the y and that's point C and that's in
Quadrant number one and then letter D
here negative 2 3 so we start here we're
going to left 2 up 3 so that puts us
right here in quadrant number 2 and
let's label that point D so remember
it's just like a number line to the
right as positive to the left is
negative down is negative up is positive
and you've got your points alright for
this problem we're crying we're trying
to determine if the point negative 4 1
is a solution to this linear equation 2x
minus 3y is equal to negative 11 when
we're given a point like this and trying
to determine if it's a solution you
really want to think of this point as an
XY pair so our first number is an X our
second number is a Y and to determine if
it's a solution we simply substitute
these and values and prex and Y and see
if it is true so this alright out is -
my X is a negative 4 my Y is a 1 and of
course we're trying to determine if this
is really equal to negative 11 so I'm
a little question mark over that equal
sign I'm also going to be careful not to
move things across the equal sign it's
really like we're kind of verify
whatever these two things are the same
so I don't want to necessarily jump to
conclusions all right let's see what we
got over here I have negative 8 minus 3
if I combine those I will get a negative
lemon and sure enough that is exactly
what we have on the other side so these
two things are equal since they are
equal we can say that negative 4 1 is a
solution for number 7 we want to graph
these lines okay in the coordinate plane
so for a we have x equals negative 2 now
here's the thing sometimes students get
a little bit confused because they see
the x axis going left and right like
this and they've they think maybe that x
equals lines also go left and right or
horizontal like that but what you can do
if you get stuck is just to make a
little table so what I'm going to do is
just make a table and I'm going to say
well Y is 1 X is negative 2 if Y is 2 X
is negative 2 y is 3 X is negative 2 you
can see no matter what Y is X is always
negative 2 if we plot these points
negative 2 1 negative 2 to negative 2 3
I see we're actually getting a vertical
line and x equals negative 2 now some
students just choose to you know
memorize that x equals lines are
vertical y equals lines are horizontal
but again if you forget so let's just
label this for a line a for B now we
have y equals 3 so just like we said y
equals lines or horizontal lines this
line is going to look like this
I'll just label that B and then for C we
have y equals 0 now this one's confusing
sometimes for students because we said
that y equals lines are horizontal lines
but 0 means that we're not going up or
down we're going to be right on the x
axis it's a little bit tough to graph
because it kind of blends in with the x
axis but I'll just label this for letter
C y equals 0 horizontal line and then DX
equals 0 you can probably guess that's
gonna actually be the y-axis
remember x equals lines are vertical
lines so I'll just kind of draw this in
a little bit darker here like this and
we'll label that D for this problem we
want to find the x and the y intercepts
of the equation negative 3x plus 5y is
equal to negative 15 anytime we're
looking for those intercepts you want to
make sure that you understand that one
of the values either X or Y will be 0
for example let's go ahead and find the
x-intercept first
so we're thinking where does it cross
the x-axis where crosses the x axis Y
will be 0 I know that seems backwards
but it really is what we need all right
so I've put in a 0 for the y knows how
its going to eliminate this term since 5
times 0 is just 0 so we'll just be left
with a 3x equals a negative 15 and then
we can divide all of that by a negative
3 so we'll get a nice positive 5 out of
this alright so how can we write that so
when X is 5 y is of course at 0 and this
is our x-intercept at 5 0 similarly we
can go ahead and find the y-intercept so
we'll write out the equation but this
time X is going to be the zero piece all
right so Y is in there everything else
is the same
and now we go trying to solve for y much
like before this term is going to go
away since I have a negative 3 times a 0
so that is just 0 and it's gone I have a
5y equals a negative 15 and now I can
divide both sides of this by 5 so this
will give me a negative 3 all right so
now we can write this out as a point so
when x is 0 so an x is 0 Y is negative 3
nice a number 9 we want to find the
slope ok for letter A what they're
giving us two points we want to find the
slope of that line that goes through
those two points the important thing for
this problem is you want to know your
slope formula so your slope formula is
this one right here you might want to
add this to your note sheet y2 minus y1
over x2 - x1 okay now when you look at
the two points you can call this point 1
or this point 1 this point 2 or this
point 2 but I'm going to pick this first
one I'm going to call it point 1 so this
is x1 comma y1
that just means point one and then x2 y2
so I'm going to do now on substituting
the values so we have negative 6 minus 1
over negative 3 minus negative 2 now
remember when you subtract it's like
adding the opposite so we get negative 7
over negative 1 which equals positive 7
so this one has a slope of Sabbat for
letter b x equals negative 2 remember we
talked about graphing earlier x equals
lines these are vertical lines and
vertical lines actually have an
undefined slope so you can either write
the word undefined or you can draw this
0 with like a line through it
I'm just gonna write undefined for
letter C y equals 3 remember y equals
lines we've talked about our horizontal
lines okay and you can see it's not
going up to the right it's not going
down to the right it's not negative its
horizontal it's a slope of 0 so we're
gonna write M equals 0 and for letter D
we have another one we have two
coordinates we want to find the slope so
back to our slope formula again I'm
going to call this point one so x1 y1
I'm gonna call this one point two x2 y2
so we've got 8 minus 2 over negative 4
minus negative 4 now remember when you
subtract it's like adding the opposite 8
minus 2 is 6 negative 4 plus 4 0 we
can't divide by zero that's undefined so
this has an undefined slope meaning that
it's going to be a vertical line if you
plot those points now if you were to get
something like this 0 divided by 6 so
the numerator is 0 and the denominator
is not 0 this would equal 0 so sometimes
students get confused by that a little
bit 0 in the numerator is 0 a 0 in the
denominator is undefined so in this case
for letter D we said undefined slope for
this problem we want to find the slope
and the y-intercept of 2x minus 3y is
equal to 18 all right let's see what we
got for this one
for the slope and the y-intercept it's
probably best to put this into
slope-intercept form
that's the one where we have Y all by
itself and then the other terms here for
M and B will represent the slope and the
y-intercept so it's a really handy form
to get what we want out of here
so to get it closer to that form we need
to move the X term to the other side so
we'll just subtract it and then we'll
need to divide everything by that
negative three so negative two divided
by negative 3 is a positive 2/3 18
divided by a negative 3 this will be a
negative as well and it'll be a negative
6 all right so now it's in that form
let's go ahead and highlight the things
we want here this 2/3 is what we call
the slope and negative 6 there's our
y-intercept negative 6 so it's all about
getting it in that right form and then
just reading off really what you want
4:11 we want to write an equation of a
line that goes through this point and
has a slope of negative 1/2 now you can
do this two different ways and I'm going
to show you both ways the first way
we're going to use the point-slope form
of the equation of the line why I want
an X 1 that's your point and M that's
your slope so let's do it that way first
so we have Y minus the y coordinate the
point equals the slope times X minus the
x coordinate of the point now we can get
this Y by itself by adding 3 to the
other side but first let's distribute 2
negative 1/2 so that's going to be
negative 1/2 X you can think it was like
8 over 1 so you multiply the numerators
together that's positive 8 the
denominators together that's 2 a
negative times the neighbor is a
positive so we get 4 okay and then here
we have Y minus 3 and then I'm going to
add 3 to both sides so we get y equals a
negative 1/2 X plus 7 now you can see
it's in the y equals MX plus B form of
the equation of the line the slope
intercept form but a lot of students are
just used to working with the
slope-intercept form
let me show you that way so you would
put it in the slope which is negative
1/2 okay that goes in for M but we don't
know what the B value is so what we can
do is we can take these x and y-values
and substitute them in so y equals 3x is
8 which we said was like 8 over 1 and
you can see that's negative 8 over 2
which reduces to negative 4 and now we
just want to get B by itself so instead
of subtracting 4 we're going to add 4 to
both sides so B equals 7 we're gonna put
that 7 back in for B right there and you
can see y equals a negative 1/2 X plus 7
just like we got doing it the first way
so either way will work whatever way you
prefer in this problem about lines we're
curious whether they are parallel
perpendicular or neither this type of
question is really talking about the
slopes of the two lines they could be
the same parallel they could be opposite
reciprocals of one another what we say
perpendicular or they could actually
just be some two lines that really are
not parallel or perpendicular what we
would say just aren't neither the key
for really seeing whether this happens
is to compare the two slopes and it'd be
nice if both the Mauryan that y equals
MX plus b form if they were then we
could just look at the end term that'd
be our slope and we could quickly
determine if they were parallel or not
so let's do a little bit of work with
this second equation here and get it
into that y equals MX beat form and that
way we can better compare the slopes so
what I'm doing here is I'm subtracting
the 10 X to the other side that looks
good and let's divide everything by a
negative 5 so 10 divided by negative 5
is a positive 2 8 divided by negative 5
will be a negative 8/5 there we go and
now we can take a much closer look at
our slopes so here's the slope of our
first line here's the slope of that
second line and we can immediately tell
that they're not the same so they are
not parallel they are not opposite
reciprocals of whatever
they're close they are very close if
they were opposite reciprocals we did
see something like 1/2 a negative 2 or
we'd see something like a negative 1/2
and a positive 2 they drill
have to be opposite in science but since
we're not seeing that you only get the
last option these two are neither
parallel nor perpendicular let's try
that same technique for our second set
of lines this second one is already in
our y equals MX b-plus form but the
first one is not so we'll do a little
bit of work with this one by moving the
3x to the other side
they'll give us a negative 3x and then
we'll need to divide through by the
negative six so negative three divided
by a negative six will give us a 1/2
negative 9 divided by a negative six we
could reduce that but I'm just gonna
leave it as negative nine six so we're
not really worried about the y intercept
anyway all right now let's go ahead and
make a comparison so there's my slope of
the second line here's my slope of the
first line and in this case they are
exactly the same so we would say that
these two lines are parallel okay number
13 we have graph and state the domain
and range of this function well notice
these vertical bars are this is an
absolute value graph you probably member
the absolute value graphs have this V
like shape okay
and what we can do is we can do this a
couple different ways we can use
transformations one way to do it is if
you look at the general form of an
absolute value equation y equals a times
the absolute value of x minus h plus K
the h and the K pick up the graph and
shift it left and right up and down the
one that's group with the X is going to
shift it in the horizontal direction but
it has the opposite effect so if it was
like minus 1 it would actually go to the
right one if it was plus one it would
actually go to the left one the K that's
a vertical shift if it's plus two would
actually go up two if it was minus two
it would go down two so just remember
the one this group of the X has the
opposite effect and then the e is
involved with stretching the graph if a
is greater than one compressing the
graph if it's between 0 and 1 and if
it's negative it's gonna reflect it over
the x-axis so a couple different ways to
do this problem but notice that this one
here is not
being shifted left to right but it is
being shifted down to we could think of
this as like our vertex this point here
where the graph bends and then the
one-half this is like a shrink but
another way to do this is to think of
this as like the slope you can say from
this point we're going rise one run two
rise one run two and because you can see
it's symmetric on both sides of this
vertex you can repeat that same process
rise one and then go the other direction
two and then you can see you're getting
like a real nice v-shaped graph the one
half is compressing it which is making
it wider the other way to do this
problem if you want is to focus on
graphing just this part y equals one
half absolute value of X just make like
a table and then what you can do once
you get those values plot the graph and
then shift it down to so that's another
option if you want
okay now speaking of the domain in the
range when we talk about domain domain
means like what can the X values be so
we think about what I normally do is I
take like a vertical line like this and
I scan across the x axis from left to
right see how the graph is going to the
left and the right forever and ever so
the X values can be anything X can be
three there's a point on the graph X can
be for it's going to be 5 etc so here
what we're gonna do is going to say the
domain is all real numbers you can use
this symbol here or you could write all
reals now for the range we're talking
about what can the y-values be I take a
horizontal line like I take my marker
here like this horizontally and I scan
from like low to high like this
direction see how there's not any y
values down here there's not any points
down here only until we get to negative
2 or higher to see this across the graph
so the Y values are gonna be at negative
2 or greater so I'm gonna say range is y
is greater than or equal to negative 2
and you got it all right in this set of
problems we want to solve and then graph
the solution on a number line the reason
why we're going for a number line in
these two instances is both of these are
inequalities so there's actually lots of
different solutions and a really good
way to represent all of those solutions
is really just graphing them out so to
solve this we want to work on isolating
X getting it all by itself to start that
off let's go ahead and
and three to all of our pieces so we'll
add a three times middle piece we'll add
a three to the left and right one this
will give us a negative three is less
than a three X less than or equal to 15
okay that X is still not quite isolated
let's go ahead and divide everything by
the positive three so let's see what we
get for that we'll get a negative 1 less
than X less than or equal to five all
right so it looks like X is our number
and it could be some number between
negative one not inclusive up to five
and that is inclusive so if we're
drawing this out on a nice number line
we want to include those endpoints and
everything in between so I'm going to
use this open parenthesis or sometimes
you might see an open circle at negative
one we'll do a hard bracket sometimes
you might see a closed circle at five
and we'll go ahead and shade in
everything in between there we go so as
long as I'm between those two spots or
inclusive of five then I know I have a
solution all right let's try that second
problem we'll see on the second one
we're still dealing with an inequality
this time it's connected with or so
we'll solve each problem separately then
go ahead and look at the combined
solution when we get to that number line
let's see well done so the first step
we're going to add 9 to both sides this
will give us a negative 2x greater than
and this will be a 20
alright that's looking good now we'll go
ahead and divide both sides by negative
two be careful when dividing or
multiplying by a negative numbers
especially when you're dealing with an
inequality like this it flips your
inequality symbol around so this would
be X is less than and now we do the math
over here just as we normally would and
this is giving us a negative 10 so X is
less than a negative 10 all right moving
on over here getting X all by itself we
will add 3 to both sides so plus the 3
plus the 3 so X is greater than or equal
to negative 7 plus 3 is a negative 4
notice how we're not really worried
about flipping the sign here because we
are not multiplying only when you
multiply or divide all right so we have
two solutions that X is less than
negative 10 or X is greater than or
equal to 8 negative 4 so we want those
two places on the number line and since
it could be in one or the other we'll go
ahead and graph them both let's see
negative 10 is on the left here so we'll
put negative 10 I'll use that
parentheses to show that I don't really
want to include the negative 10 and X
could be smaller than that so we will
shade everything lower we also want to
say negative 4 so it's to the right of
negative 10 and it could be greater than
so we'll shade to the right of that so I
really have these two intervals nice
okay number 15 it says graph the
inequalities in the XY coordinate plane
so we've got two different examples now
the first one letter a see how Y is by
itself
a lot of students find that it's easier
just to get the Y by itself and then
graph and this one already is so it's in
the slope-intercept form so what we're
going to do is we're going to find that
y-intercept one two three four five six
crosses right there at six the slope is
negative one half so from here we're
going down one over two down one over
two and notice how it's less than but
not equal to that means that this is
going to be a dashed or dotted line
if it was equal to would be a solid line
meaning that it includes the points on
that on that line but you see all the Y
values are less than the Y controls the
vertical
rection up and down so if the y-values
are less than we're shading below that
line
and so you could shade straight down
like so now another way to do this is to
pick a test point and a good test point
to pick is the origin 0 0 and what you
would do is you would put 0 in for y 0
in for X so that comes out to 0 is less
than 6 so that's actually true 0 is less
than 6 so that's the side of the plane
okay the side of this line that you want
to shade if it was false then you would
shade the other side so two different
options test point method or less than
below greater than above the Y controls
the vertical direction for letter B
notice how the variables are both on the
left side of this inequality so you can
either rearrange it in equality to get
the Y by itself or you can do the
intercept method so if you set X equal
to 0 let's make a little table here then
divide by negative 5y would be 2 if you
set Y to 0 divided by 2 X is going to be
negative 5 so all we did right there was
just find the intercepts so we have 0 2
and negative 5 0 it's less than or equal
to in this case so it's going to be a
solid line okay and then now you don't
want to make this mistake where you say
oh this is less than you know Mario's
told me to shade below that only works
at the y is by itself right so what
we're gonna do here we're going to do
the test point method I'm going to put
in 0 0 ok which is this origin point
right here 0 minus 0 that's 0 is 0 less
than or equal to negative 10 no zero is
actually greater than all the negative
numbers so this point here is false we
don't want to shade on this side we want
to shade on the other side now that
seems too complicated just rearrange
this equation get the Y by itself so
let's go ahead and do that method so
we're going to subtract 2x from both
sides so negative 5y is less than or
equal to negative 2x minus 10 then we're
going to divide everything by negative 5
to get the Y by itself so these are
going to cancel you get Y is okay 2/5 X
plus 2 but remember when you multiply or
divide both sides of an inequality by a
negative number what happens to the sign
and a new quality sign actually flips so
now this is greater than and now it's
making sense you know in the context of
what we did in the letter aid the plus
two that's your y-intercept the slope is
2/5 and greater than or equal to our
shading above or on that line any point
in this region will make this inequality
true for this problem we want to solve a
system of equations using the
substitution method the idea is that we
already have the first equation solved
for X so I can take what it's equal to
and put it in the second equation watch
how this goes so the second equation is
X minus a 3 y equals negative 1 but
instead of putting that X there since
the first one is already solved for X
we'll put what it's equal to so I
replaced X with 2y minus 4 right now I
have an equation that only has Y's in it
so we'll get the Y's all by itself so 2y
minus 4 minus 3y equals negative 1 that
looks good I can combine together the
Y's so a positive 2 minute negative 3
gives me a negative 1 now I can work on
getting wild by itself so let's add 4 to
both sides and multiply by a negative 1
and we'll see that we get a negative 3
for the Y so that's looking pretty good
now that we have one variable we can go
ahead and put it back into either one of
our equations and we'll get the X
variable since the first one is already
solved for X it's probably a good place
to put it so we'll go ahead with that
one X is equal to 2y or in this case
being a negative 3 and now we'll just go
ahead and do a little bit of algebra and
see what X is equal to so 2 times a
negative 3 is a negative 6 negative 6
minus 4 is a negative 10 so we have X is
equal to negative 10 we can either write
this as a ordered pair where I have my x
and y or you can just go ahead and leave
it as x equals negative 10 y equals
negative 3 as long as it's clear what
each of the variables represent okay
number 17 it says solve the system using
the elimination method so when we do the
elimination method we're trying to add
these two equations together
to eliminate either the exes or the Y's
or you can subtract the equations and
eliminate the XS or the Y's I usually
find adding to be easier and most
students normally do so ideally what we
want when we try to combine these is we
want one of the quantities to be
negative one of the quantities to be
positive we want them to have the same
coefficient so when we add them together
they'll cancel out so the question for
this one is do we want to eliminate the
XS or the Y's here you can see that you
know it's there's not like a really
simple way to do this one we're going to
have to multiply both equations by a
constant and it looks like 3 & 2 the
lowest common multiple is 6 so I'm gonna
multiply this top equation by 2 that's
going to give us negative 6y I'm gonna
multiply this bottom equation by 3 this
is going to give us positive 6y then
when we add them together the Y's will
cancel out so let's go ahead and do that
let's distribute the 2 do everything in
this equation that's going to make this
8x minus 6y equals 20 and we distribute
the 3 we get 15 X plus 6y equals 3 now
if we add straight down see how the Y's
are going to cancel out we get 23 x
equals 23 and we just want to solve for
x by dividing both sides by 23 and you
can see that x equals 1 now if we take
the 1 we can put it back in for this X
or this X or this X or this X it doesn't
matter any one of the equations will
work I'll just do this top one here 4
times X is 1 minus 3y equals 10 so this
is 4 if we subtract 4 from both sides we
get negative 3y equals 6 divide both
sides by negative 3 and you can see that
Y is going to come out to negative 2
and so our final answer we want to write
it as a coordinate pair 1 comma negative
2 this represents you know where these
two lines are crossing or intersecting
if you want to check your work if you
put 1 in for X negative 2 and for y
you'll get 10 same thing over here
you'll get 1 if it makes both equations
true you know you have that common point
of intersection all right in this
problem we've got a bunch of the
different little ones and we're using
the rules of exponents to simplify them
as much as possible since we're using a
lot of various different rules sometimes
you might see a certain rule and you can
apply it go
do so but always check it to see if
there's any other rules that you can
maybe later apply all right so what I'm
looking at the first one here at the top
the thing that really strikes out at me
is this - in the 8th I can reduce those
2 goes into 8 4 times so that first
part's really just going to be 8 1/4 for
our rules of exponents on the second
piece I can see that I have a y in the
top and a Y in the bottom so I can
subtract their exponents so let's go
ahead and write this as 1/4 so that's
the first piece right there and I'll say
Y of 3 minus 5 so there's where I'm
using that rule subtracting the
exponents continuing on 3 minus 5 is
equal to a negative 2 so you can leave
it like this or if you want to turn it
back into a fraction that's completely
okay remember that with negative
exponents they end up on the bottom so
this would be 1 divided by 4 y squared
nice all right on to the next one for
our rules of exponents here we want to
apply the 4 to both the terms on the
inside so this 4 will go on the to the
negative 2 and it will also go on the X
cubed all right
so negative 2 to the 4th power that's
the same as negative 2 times itself 4
different times now give us a positive
16 for the second piece we can use our
rules of exponents to multiply those
exponents together so this will be 3
times 4 on the top they're multiplying 3
times where when we get 12 and so this
is equal to 16 X to the 12th right
here's an interesting one we see that
both pieces are in parentheses but
really everything is just being
multiplied together so we could actually
start combining things and saying well
what's 5 times a negative two and then
what's an a times an a cubed and a B
squared times a B so really just
reshuffling the multiplication and now
we can go ahead and combine them five
times the negative 2 is a negative tenth
the rules of exponents here would say we
need to add the exponents so I have a 1
in it
and be a to the fourth power adding
exponents for this one on the B's 2 plus
1 would equal B to the 3rd alright
looking good alright the next one we
have three different terms here again
they're all being multiplied so we'll
just really focus on their exponents 2
plus 3 plus 0 2 plus 3 plus 0 would be a
5 and so we're done with that one now
interestingly enough that's not the only
way you can do this one you might also
recognize that one of your rules for
exponents says that anything to the 0
power is 1 so you could have actually
reduced this and called it 1 and gotten
the same answer that's because you would
end up combining these two so X to the 2
plus 3 and then you'd multiply that
result by 1 but hey one x thing is
itself so you'd end up right back at X
to the fifth alright one last one here
we're dealing with a fraction to the
third power and you're going to apply
that power of three to all of the terms
you're doing this because they're all
being multiplied so I have to the third
C to the third 3 to the third and this
is ad squared to the third right for the
numbers we can go ahead and do the math
in there so 2 to the third is 8 and I
have C cubed off to the bottom 3 cubed
would be a 27 here we use those rules of
exponents to go ahead and multiply the
two terms so 2 times 3 would be 6
alright and that would be the last one
on there okay for number 19 we've got
two parts a and B we want to write a
scientific number in standard notation
like a regular number and we want to
write a standard number in scientific
notation so the key with scientific
notation is you have a one digit number
from 1 to 9 in front of the decimal
point the rest of the remaining
significant digits to the right or after
the decimal point
times 10 to a power now when you think
of scientific numbers when you have a
positive exponent here this tells us
that it's a really
large number when you have a negative
exponent this tells us it's a really
small number so that's something to keep
in mind 10 to the 5th really means 10
times 10 times 10 times 10 times 10 it's
like five tens multiplied together and
you can visualize that you know this is
going to be ten thousand right now a
hundred thousand sorry 100 thousand and
so if you were to multiply two point
five seven times a hundred thousand of
course that's gonna be a really large
number but an easy way to do this
problem is if you have a positive
exponent just go ahead and move that
that number of places to the right the
decimal point so you have two point five
seven we're gonna move it one two three
four five and I'm going to put my
placeholders in here so this is going to
be two five seven zero zero zero that's
two hundred and fifty seven thousand
okay for Part B now we're going the
opposite direction we have a standard
number we want to put into scientific
notation like so again we only want that
single digit between you know one two
nine in front of the decimal point we
don't want two digits three digits right
no digits we want just a single digit so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
well how many places gonna have to move
this decimal point one two three four
places that's one point two five times
10 to the negative fourth now remember
we said when it's a negative exponents a
very small number when it's a positive
exponents a very large number the other
way to look at it is see 10 to the
negative fourth is really like 1 over 10
to the positive fourth because when you
have a negative exponent you take the
reciprocal so this is kind of like
dividing by 10,000 imagine if you took
1.25 and you divided it by 10,000 it
would become very small so that's the
key is negative exponent really small
number positive ex-mo really large
number and you got it all right for this
next problem we're working to add
subtract or multiply polynomials
depending on how they're put together
there's bunches of them here so let's go
ahead and start with the first one and
the first one we see that we're actually
subtracting two polynomials and we can
tell because I have the first polynomial
minus the second polynomial for these
you really want to think of like terms
so here I have a term with X to the
fifth but there is no other x to the
fifth term over here so this is like 2x
- v - 0 so that will just be a 2 X to
the 5th term it would changes for that
one next I'm looking for X to the fourth
terms I don't see any of those and now I
can move on to X to the 3rd terms and we
do have one of these here we don't have
any over here so really to take care of
the X to the 3rd terms you want to think
of this as 0 - 3 X to the 3rd and
because of that minus sign here we're
gonna pick up a negative sign on our
term alright that takes care of that one
onto the X Squared's and I see that
there are X Squared's in both of our
polynomials so I have a negative 3x
squared - a 5 x squared - 3 minus a 5
will give us a combined - 8 x squared
right and on to our constant terms here
we have a negative 2 minus 4 for a
negative 6 so this would be our combined
polynomial onto the next one here we're
taking care of multiplication between
two polynomials for this you want to
think of the distributive process so
this first little polynomial is going to
go to all of the terms on the inside
you're going to do the numbers and the
variables as well so 2 times 3 would
equal 6 then I can use my rules for
exponents to add the exponents together
here this will give us Y to the fifth
and I'm on to the next term 2 times a
negative 7 is a negative 14 take my Y's
and add their exponents 3 plus 1 is a 4
on to the last term 2 times 2 is a 4
there are no Y terms here or you can
think of it as Y to the 0 power so we'll
just be left with Y to the 3rd as our
last term right here again we have
multiplying of two polynomials this is a
good situation where we can use the foil
method so we'll take our first outside
inside and last term's and put them
together let's start off with those
first terms 2x times 4x would equal an 8
at
squared outside terms would be the two X
and the one so I'll give us just a 2x
inside terms negative 3 times 4 is a
negative 12x and the last term's
negative 3 so with our outside and
inside we can actually go ahead and
combine those together this will give us
a polynomial of 8x squared minus 10x
minus 3 very nice the next one we can
also use foil but I want to point out
something that will save you a lot of
time notice how these two polynomials
are exactly the same except for this
little symbol right here one has a plus
sign and one has a minus sign in cases
where you're multiplying two binomials
together like that it means that your
outside and your inside terms will be
the same but opposite in sign the
punchline to all of this is that they
will drop away entirely don't worry I
won't skip that step let's go ahead and
take a look at what happens with the
first two terms 5y times a 5y will give
us a 25 Y squared the outside will be a
negative 20 Y and the inside will be a
positive 20 Y so they're the same except
for opposite in sign in the last terms 4
times 4 is a 16 since one of them is
negative that'll give us a negative 16
the outside and inside terms will cancel
away since one is plus and one is minus
leaving us with just a 25 y squared
minus 16 all right and one last one this
is also a good one that you can foil
because you want to recognize that this
two represents that we have another
polynomial just like this one being
multiplied by itself sometimes it's nice
to actually go ahead and write these out
in the expanded version or just so you
can see that you really do have two of
these multiplied together now you can
also use a shortcut for this one since
they are exactly the same essentially
your outside and inside terms will be
the same so you only have to compute one
of those and then double it but again
foil works pretty good so I'll just look
at all the steps and go from there to
see times to see it would be 4c
squared outside would be +6 see and
inside is exactly the same another +6
see my last terms are 3 times 3 which is
9 then I can work to go ahead and
combine those inner terms so 4c squared
plus 12 C plus 9
there we go that's our last polynomial
for this set of problems okay follow us
over to part 2 I'll have a link to the
video right there where we'll continue
on with this algebra 1 final exam review